YUFENG GUO: Natural Language
processing is not an easy task.
And when it comes to
domain-specific language,
things get even trickier.
Standard pre-trained
benchmark models
aren't always useful in
industry-specific applications.
So how can we train a
text classification system
on custom data?
Stay tuned to find out.
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we're going to look
at how to use AutoML
natural language
to build a custom
text classifier,
using a dataset
from Stack Overflow.
Stack Overflow is an
incredibly useful tool.
And it has saved me
on many occasions.
But sometimes it gets
tedious tagging questions.
And I wish it
would automatically
generate or at least
suggest some tags when
posting a question.
So today, we will try to
build a machine learning model
for recommending tags for
Stack Overflow questions
about machine learning.
To get started, we're going
to need some training data.
I have spoken about the BigQuery
datasets program before,
and it comes to the
rescue here again.
With over 25 gigabytes of
Stack Overflow questions here,
I think we've got enough
material to work with.
Using AutoML Natural Language
is quite convenient for our use
case because I don't
necessarily know
what I want to build initially.
It would be great to be
able to easily experiment
with a couple of
different options.
So to start out, let's
just try building
a simple classification model
that just differentiates
between whether a question
is asking about TensorFlow
or other, something else.
The SQL query we're going to
use to pre-process this data,
it's a little bit involved.
We'll combine the title and
the text fields together
into one long string
of text, strip out
all that HTML
formatting tag nonsense.
We don't need that.
And we'll replace those vertical
bars in the tags with commas.
So we'll limit our
questions to only
be those that are tagged with
TensorFlow, Keras, Matplotlib,
Pandas, and Scikit Learn.
That way it's just
machine learning topics.
So at this point, you might be
wondering if we shouldn't just
make a tag recommendation
system by writing,
say, an IF statement.
In some cases, you'd be right.
But there's definitely
still questions out there
which don't mention the word
TensorFlow, even though they
are about TensorFlow.
So to even things out
and prevent the model
from using the word TensorFlow
to basically cheat and find
those questions
about TensorFlow,
let's replace all of the
obvious words with, let's say,
the word avocado.
For your work model, you
can choose a different food.
Now that our Stack
Overflow questions are all
about avocado datasets
and avocado classifiers,
we can use AutoML
Natural Language
to train a model that
decides whether a question is
about TensorFlow
or something else.
Training AutoML Natural Language
is very straightforward.
And you just click Train.
It seems to have yielded
good results for us.
And we can test it with
a question from outside
of our training set.
Here's one about
the .net framework.
And the model seems to correctly
recognize that it is not
about TensorFlow.
Great.
So now we can look at
something more useful
than just TensorFlow or
not, labeling the questions
with up to five different
tags all about those different
machine learning libraries.
We can use our dataset,
just as before,
and replace the library
names with avocado.
And we'll need to update
the labels so that instead
of just TensorFlow and other,
we have all five libraries
represented.
And we can see in
AutoML Natural Language
that the datasets
are roughly balanced.
And once we wait for the
training to complete,
we actually have quite some
good results from the training.
I was very happy with this.
AutoML Natural Language shows
not just the training scores,
but it also shows false
positives and false negatives
for each of those five classes.
So this helps us spot potential
errors in our data or errors
in the model.
We can try a couple of
different sample questions
and paste them into the
Predict tab of the interface
and see if those tags and
the scores are reasonable.
And in our case, they seem to
have turned out pretty well.
AutoML Natural Language allowed
us to quickly and easily test
out some ideas about our data
with different ways of labeling
and training that model.
We didn't have to deal
with tokenization,
word representation
models, or embeddings.
All we needed to do was
have an understanding
of our dataset and the task
we were hoping to achieve,
and then see if the system
could make a model that
was suitable for our use case.
This meant that we could focus
on the problem we are trying
to solve, tagging Stack
Overflow questions,
rather than figuring
out how to model text.
Now that we know it's
possible to build this model
and that the data is there,
we can weigh the trade off
between building a
custom model ourselves
versus just using the
model that we already made
from AutoML Natural Language.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed it,
click that Like button
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out
the expanded blog post
I have linked below in the
description for more details
and examples.
And be sure to check out
AutoML Natural Language
and see what interesting
models you can build.
[MUSIC PLAYING]